we get a fellow streamer round five here
we go big time match up oh
also i'm playing
wow i think i am frozen
let's play d6 he's gonna play this one
no
we get a little pierce action okay okay
he's playing one of these okay okay
um shout out to john i know let's play
bd7 we'll crouch he sometimes streams
use bishop e7
will play like this
um how do i want to handle this
let's go c6
i wonder if he's going to try and use
the clock as a weapon queen c7
we'll play like so maybe try to build
this
little uh eventual pond wave hopefully
you ho thank you for gifting a sub to
never play f6 play this first yeah been
a while since eric and i played like in
a uh
serious game let's call it
i'm allowing some center of work trick
we played some bullet
but uh been a while since we played in
the tournament like title tuesday so
cool to see shout out to eric and his
viewers he's streaming this as well
so maybe we'll get a side-by-side cut
at some point it looks a little bit dude
it takes
my h4
let's take this way
so 94 i have not a five
i think i might go for uh
rook f8 bishop f8 a rookie bishop
let me consider this move also sets up
like we have three ideas
g6 is perhaps somewhat logical for black
it's a bit tricky when you face this
because this can be kind of menacing for
sure and maybe queen e2
[Music]
let's actually go here
i'm going to try to send the knight
around i think
maybe this
yeah i'll play like this oh i was
expecting bishop effect not knight f8
play that a little bit too quickly
it's probably a fine move though
like g3 h4
definitely a little pressure though so i
need to be careful
i think he's trying to prepare h5 so let
me think what i'm going to do about that
maybe because
some counter play so let's go here
he wants to play c5 eventually
like b4h5 takes takes try for this
he's trying to slowly roll me over here
so i need some counter play towards the
center ideally defend the pawn and cover
c4 in the event of c5
h5 is hard to stop
i mean black could play h5 himself but
it doesn't go right
i wonder if i can take on
e7
and bishop g5
time is very good here
so i'm the one using the clock as a
weapon
queen f5 threatening this
tricky there's this idea as well
i think i can just take on f6
you just
have his rook d6 queen g5
and knight c4 also looks great
very tricky
but this is a bit more concrete
so if i lose a knight then i take on g6
i'm ready to hit the rook
bring the knight into maybe f5
there's a funny line
[Music]
so bishop d bishop e4 bishop d5
setting up the triple fork and if it
takes i could maybe even take the rook
first
the bishop just has no squares
this drops material but i think i have
to play it that's a square
now i can take and play i mean there's
also not a five
and take another five
there's also knight d5
there's also this move
this is simpler
yeah that's not gonna work i was aware
of that i thought i could just take here
hitting the rook
um tricky
key five
winning for white
oh no my queen oh fancy threatening
i should all be okay
i got crushed that game okay
that was a nice game